well we've gotten the latest inflation
numbers and year-over-year inflation has
now gone up to 9.1
that's on the basis of june to june so
that is we got that report in july but
it's for june 2021
through june 2022
these are very very high numbers and the
question now is
how long is this going to go on i still
am sticking to my original prediction
about how long this is going to go on
and i'm going to explain to you why
one really important thing to understand
is i believe we're already seeing the
decline of inflation in july but we just
got the june numbers and that's not yet
reflected and one of the big elements
that we look at with inflation
is gas prices why is it gas prices well
gas prices themselves relate not only to
what is the budget of the average
household that has gas-powered vehicles
but also many of the products that we
regularly get everything from grocery
store to other things they come on
trucks when gas prices are higher the
transportation costs are higher and it
raises the cost of other things airline
tickets are another element of of
inflation and jet fuel is related to the
price of oil and the price of gas and so
my belief is that the public data about
declining gas prices
also
uh shows that the next the july numbers
which we will get in august are going to
be lower and i'm going to tell you the
mechanism through which this happens in
a moment first real quick i want to tell
you about our sponsor
my heritage
i love tracking my genealogy and dna and
there's just this sort of reality that
if your ancestors are jewish and they
were moving around due to political
circumstances before and during world
war ii
it can just be really tough to figure
out
from most records sort of like where
you're from and that's one of the great
things about the dna test by myheritage
which was able to give me a more
detailed breakdown than any other test
on the market i sent my heritage a quick
cheek swab
it opened me up to all sorts of
fascinating discoveries about my family
you get a breakdown of your origins
across 42 ethnicities in over 2100
geographic regions you can find new
family members who match to your dna i
trust my heritage with my privacy
because of their policy
of never selling or licensing your data
period
you remain the owner of your data my
results
not shockingly
98.8 percent ashkenazi jewish of origins
in poland and ukraine and russia and
romania all of which i knew about
but also hungary germany east and
central europe i did not know about that
and also 1.2
english
which is pretty interesting i've been
using my heritage for years to connect
with cousins and other people
and now i also have the dna information
and it's fascinating start making
exciting discoveries about your own
origins get free shipping on your dna
kit when you use my link in the
description and use the code pacman
okay so
we are already seeing in july
a significant decline in gas prices now
closing in on 10 percent
we have not yet seen inflation data that
includes july and this is because
inflation data is delayed by a month in
mid august we are going to get the july
data
my expectation roughly
four
four five months ago
was that inflation would be high
until the end of summer and that then we
would see
the quote summer driving season cooling
off a little bit the summer travel
season cooling off a little bit and we
would start to see a decline sometime
between august and october i still
believe that that's what we're going to
see i believe that declining gas prices
uh homes sitting on the market a little
longer i think these are all signs that
inflation has peaked now as i've said
before
humans myself included are terrible at
making economic predictions i'm not
making any financial decisions on the
basis of my belief i believe that we are
now at peak inflation and it will start
to decline i believe that the next
inflation report will be lower than what
we just got but my financial strategy
remains the same i'm buying the lowest
cost
index funds maintaining my asset
allocation which includes a little tiny
slice in crypto
more in cash
real estate and then a stock bond split
that's appropriate based on my age and i
just keep contributing every month
because at the end of the day i don't
know i'm speculating that inflation has
peaked and also by the way
whether i'm right or wrong
it doesn't really change my risk
tolerance it doesn't really change
anything about how much cash should i
hold or what percentage of assets should
i have in bonds so not only am i not
making any recommendations based on my
prediction i don't even think there's
anything that would or should be changed
on that basis so we will see
mid
mid-august
right between the 10th and 15th of
august i believe we will get the latest
inflation numbers which will reflect
july
i expect it to be lower than 9.1 i
believe 9.1 is the peak if i'm wrong
i'll just tell you i'm terrible at
predicting this stuff and we'll see
where things go from there